in the last three years the consumer
drone industry is absolutely exploded in
2014 one top drone manufacturer reported
almost 500 million dollars in revenue
the FAA estimates the industry will top
90 billion dollars within a decade and
now drones aren't just being used for
aerial photography and stunt aerobatic
hobbyists have found a new use for them
making them fight yeah top ugly opponent
from classic down them to the ground and
remain airborne the rules of battle are
simple three strikes and you're out
each drone studs with three points and
once they hit zero they're gone every
time a drone crashes into the ground or
gets tangled in the net it loses a point
if both groans crash which happens a lot
it's a push and no points are taken away
once a drone gets tangled or grounded
the operator has 90 seconds to fix it
and get it back up in the air
but you should never try to do this with
your thousand-dollar DJI phantom or 3dr
solo UAVs that compete in this game of
drones are custom-built for battle they
have durable polymer airframes easily
swappable propellers and fast access to
their internal components so they can be
quickly fixed during a battle game of
drones comm saws a complete kit for
around $400 I read online about battling
brothers and when I saw that I was like
I have to so I drove all night with no
sleep to battle at 10 o'clock in the
morning and I bought 10 of these I just
love everything about it
now I'll tell you I've never been hurt
in a cage these are big enough you see
him come in they don't move fast enough
always so it's easy to get out of the
way
as you can see interest in drones and
their technological capabilities are
both taking off big-time but not all
drone enthusiasts are created the same
look at that what's the posture was that
separate dock Brian might have a patent
claim on on the flux ambassador but
that's coming though some want to race
them and others just want to ruin them
in the sky
the whole rock